hey guys Pete here this is my top
moments recap for twin peak season 3
episode 15 I really enjoyed this episode
there were a lot of payoffs for things
that I wanted to see I'm not sure what
the general consensus is but I thought
it was pretty good all the way around
and it sets things up pretty good going
into the last three episodes so quick
spoiler warning if you haven't watched
episode 15 yet then you're not going to
want to watch this video and with that
let's jump right in of course the first
big moment was Nadine telling Edie she
wants him to be free I think what's
really funny about this is that at no
time to bring this sequence and it
wasn't short I mean there was probably
it was probably 10 minutes long I
suppose that I feel like it was actually
gonna work out we saw the looks on Ed's
face at gas farm he gets to the double r
and Norma can't talk it first and it has
a really strange feeling and then we see
him agonizing their music is perfect
inside the Double R Otis Redding just
fantastic and then as he's there after
he asked for a cyanide capsule we see
her hand on his shoulder and man it was
pretty good he asked her to marry him
she says yes and the world didn't
explode right then because I was still
not really sure that it was all going to
work out but it was a great payoff for
the old connection to the old series and
they really kind of threw us for a loop
by saying that they didn't get together
in the secret history and sort of
changing things up a little bit and it
looks like dr. Jacobi's conversation and
all of his ranting on YouTube or
whatever he does actually did have a
purpose and that was for Nadine to
realize she needed to let him go and
bigad finally getting to be with Norma
the next big moment was evil coops
arrival at the convenience store it was
the exact convenience store that we saw
way back during the Trinity test he
arrives and he goes upstairs which I
thought was pretty cool because we all
noticed that there were stairs but they
didn't look like there was anything like
a second floor in the
in store but of course you just
disappear into Sydney and end up inside
instead a lot of crazy stuff going on in
here first we see that wallpaper that he
approaches a woodsman who is sitting
there drooling black liquid and that
could be related to Billy or that you
know the drunk in the jail he tells me
what to see Jeffries he does something
was electricity flips a switch or
something along those lines and we get
the shot of the jumping man which we've
all been waiting for
and then another woodsman comes and
brings him down in the direction of
another staircase and as he moves we see
trees and like I said the whole thing
was just pretty fantastic after they go
upstairs we see that Jeffries is there
but he's more like a teapot combined
with that thing we saw in the Giant's
house or the mobs own area where NATO
jumps off the edge so not exactly sure
what he is we do get a introduction of a
new character here who unlocks the door
for him locks and unlocks the door for
evil Koopa we don't really get a good
idea of who she is after arriving we're
filled Jeffries is able to pretty much
instantly ask them about Judi who Judi
is why he doesn't want to talk about
Judi we found out a couple things right
here one he says you're still Cooper or
you are Cooper he says is I think the
exactly he said it and he also says that
he is already met Judy now none of this
really makes sense on the surface does
he mean that you still have some Cooper
in you and did he mean that evil coupe
has met Judy or did he meet that either
one of them at some time has met Judy so
yes it wasn't really clear but we did
get some interesting stuff Cooper got a
number evil coupe got a number and again
I couldn't tell if this was the number
four we didn't see a whole telephone
number I don't think but then when he's
outside he instantly Texas that Las
Vegas text that we saw Diane received
before so I wasn't sure if that was
insinuating that he was you
using the number that Phillip Jeffries
just gave him or what but it was the
evolution of Jeffries I guess you could
say since David Bowie passed on it was a
boy factor but it was a good job I mean
we had the spirit of the character
Philip Jeffries for sure but we're going
to have to see how all that stuff plays
out as they are finishing up their
conversation a phone begins to ring and
eventually evil coupe answers it after
Jeffries disappears that sends him
outside where Richard Horne is waiting
for after kicking his ass a little bit
and taking his gun and telling them not
to threaten him anymore
we find out that Audrey is in fact
Richard's mother we also find out that
she had a picture of agent Cooper and
her stuff which could mean that well it
could mean a lot of things let's leave
it at that for now but when they got in
the car it sure felt like it was a
father and son he says we'll talk on the
ride and it sort of felt like it was
making a sync at least that Richard had
just met his dad before we move on to
the next big moment I guess it's worth
noting that the convenience store seems
to move around after they leave it
pretty much disappeared so that could
come in later to be important after that
the next big moment was not Steven
killing himself although that was a
moment don't get me wrong the next big
moment for me was seeing mark frost
being the dog walking guy and that was
super cool
he is playing his old character Sheryl
pons the weatherman from season 1 but we
don't get any more backstory on him he
did go to tell Karl rod what he saw but
he didn't really we don't know if he
actually lives at the trailer park at
the fat trout or not it kind of seemed
like it but yeah the next big moment was
I think we found out that Steven
probably killed Becky although it's not
a hundred percent clear because he was
so drugged out it was a little bit hard
to piece things together but I feel like
that's what he was saying he may have
just shot at her it might not have been
her at all but it seemed that way
interesting what other people think he
had one more bullet to the magazine when
Cyril pond came by Kirsten ran around
the other side of the tree and then we
heard him take his own life as far as we
know the next big moment for me was ZZ
Top's
sharp-dressed man I don't know why they
chose this home but I'm really happy
that they did and it wasn't a
performance it was just a volume meter
was that song playing in the background
but it led right into the next big
moment which was Freddie psyche
unloaded with the pink glove and it is a
devastating weapon they put two guys in
intensive care who were beating on James
it was kind of weird the setup for that
but whatever he ended up nearly killing
them after that they went straight to
the next big moment which was well
actually we had a small stop where we
found out that there was a family that
was Dougie Jones and his wife Jane that
were not to correct people in the FBI I
wouldn't call that a moment the next one
was Chantal showing up and killing
Duncan Todd and his assistant and just
in case we might not get the idea or we
might think this was the doubleheader on
the way out she says one down one to go
something along those lines so we know
that dougie coupe is probably the next
person on her list we see that James and
Freddie have been locked up and it's
starting to seem like everyone that's in
the basement of the Twin Peaks Sheriff
Department is going to be important
won't get into it too much but think
about the combination of people you have
down there and it kind of does chad is
the odd man out and I think that he has
an equal importance probably because of
that but I don't have any good theories
on how that goes like I mentioned we did
see the woodsman dribbling what looked
like black liquid as well so that could
be a hint that the drum is a woodsman
but I don't know the next big moment was
a sequence of moments and they all had
to do with dougie coupe as he was eating
his chocolate cake after having a pretty
sweet little moment with Jani E he
started to shuffle things around star
buttons and then the TV turned on he
heard the name Gordon Cole on the TV and
he definitely looked like he jumped to
an attention we've had a lot of false
alarms here but I think this could be
the one because he jumped into action I
don't know what else to call it he
crawls across the floor with his fork in
hand he hears the noise at the
electrical outlet which is what drives
like you draws him there he sticks a
fork in it and then of course we don't
find out what happens in the aftermath
except for that he definitely got a jolt
now I'm not saying that it's not
possible that the next episode won't
start with him in the doctor's office
and doctor says Dougie did you stick a
fork in the electrical outlet and he
repeats the word outlet but I think this
is the closest and the best opportunity
we have for him to wake up and it's the
right time as well I kind of feel like
in the last two episodes he'll be
awakened back to normal so we'll have to
wait and see what happens then the next
heart wrenching both beautiful and just
sad sad moment was with the log Lady
Margaret Coulson she called talked on
the phone and it's just really an
amazing scene I mean I can't really do
it justice to explain it any better than
it was you should watch it again I know
I have watched him more than once I was
close to tears on the first watch to be
honest I've talked about this before in
other videos but the fact that she is
this is like a real thing you know I
mean she's close to death in real life
when she shoots these scenes and it was
really just incredible it was sad but it
was really well done at the same time I
really liked how deputy Hawke just
listened he didn't say anything he just
let her talk an interesting thing was is
in the credits we've had a show that was
dedicated to Katherine Coulson before
the actress but I noticed on this one in
the credits it was dedicated to Margaret
um which is the log lady's name so that
was really cool there was also the after
scene here that was pretty interesting
whenever Hawk calls them in and tells
Andy and Lucie and Frank what happened
kind of
harassing her Frank was sitting there in
the dark looking at images of fish but
yeah that was it was just a really cool
tribute to her Audrey is still trapped
inside of something that's the best way
I can describe it this time Charlie's
ready to leave but she can't get herself
to put her coat on and it's she's
trapped I don't know if she's trapped
for sure there's something going on is
she in a coma is she having a nightmare
I have no idea but something's not right
at the end she does start choking
Charlie which I don't know that's could
have any effect on her situation or not
but yeah she choked them out or she was
choking in the process of choking him
and the final big moment was the
Roadhouse scene this time was kind of
interesting too big biker guys come in
and the girl is sitting at the table
really paying attention to the band and
think it's going to be a thing but they
just grab her and put her on the floor
and she doesn't even really react to it
at the end notice he starts to scream
and that was a big moment I think
because even though we didn't figure out
what was going on there it kind of felt
like a mirror of something else almost
and I don't know it just felt important
to me but let me know what you guys
think I thought it was a great episode I
felt a little bit like [ __ ] it's coming
to an end but it was good to find out
what's going on with the pillow
Geoffrey's character I think dougie coop
will be back to his old self in the next
episode but I can't be sure and Norma
and Ed man that was a big one
they cut together let's hope that
nothing bad happens please give this
video a like if you enjoyed it make sure
you subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already turn on notifications so
you know when I upload new videos follow
me on Twitter interact with me over
there or Instagram or like my Facebook
page thanks for watching guys I'll talk
to you soon